Sleep.
Sleep, sleep, sleep,
it is a very complicated subject,
falling asleep, staying asleep.
It's something we've all struggled with for years.
I know I'm not alone.
In fact, a recent study done
by the National Sleep Foundation found over the half
of our country has issues with sleep.
I'm surprised it's that little,
and it's time to break this cycle.
So, let's meet Alicia,
who came to us asking for advice.
Roll the tape.
(clock ticking faintly)
Hey, guys, so I had a long day today.
I had to work the double.
I got home about an hour ago.
I'm gonna try to get some sleep, I have to be up at 6:00,
around 6:30, get the kids up,
get them off to school and start my day at work.
So, I'm hoping I could sleep through the night,
get a good five, five and a half hours
of straight sleep uninterrupted.
(clock ticking faintly)
I woke up twice last night.
I didn't actually fall asleep
until about 2:15, and I was kind of tossing and turning.
I was a little bit hot,
and then I finally got into my sleep,
and then I woke up around 4:00,
and then I dozed back off for a minute,
and then was back up at about 5:45.
I am pretty tired.
I can feel that I do have a mild headache.
Hopefully I'll feel better,
get some energy and move around
once I get out the shower.
(clock ticking faintly)
I'm up and out, and I got my first cup
of coffee for the day.
I'm feeling okay right now, a little bit sleepy,
but I'm just trying to push through,
see what the day brings.
(clock ticking faintly)
It's midday.
I feel like I'm starting to crash, I'm extremely exhausted.
I think I'm gonna need another cup of coffee to help me
power through and get through the rest of my day.
(clock ticking faintly)
I'm getting ready for bed and I am dreading this
because I know I'm going to have to do everything
all over again tomorrow.
This is an awful cycle
that needs to break because I am so tired.
Alicia,
I am just anxious for you.
Alicia, hi!
(loud applause)
Hi, Drew.
How are you?
Tired, (laughs) but I'm good, I'm good.
How long have you been having these sleep issues?
I've been having these sleep issues for about two years.
You know, I'm a doctor, I'm a psychologist.
I work in a psychiatric hospital
as well as a correctional facility,
so sleep is imperative for what I do,
but sometimes I'm just so exhausted.
I have migraines often.
So, it's just horrible, and I don't understand
why there are times that I can be in bed for eight hours
and I am still exhausted once I wake up,
and I just don't understand why.
Alicia, am I correct, that you work at Rikers Island?
Yes.
And how long have you worked there?
For two years.
Right around when your sleep problems started?
Yes. (chuckles)
Okay.
All right, well, I am not the sleep expert,
but I am seeing two patterns here.
That said, we have a sleep expert.
So, I'll speak to some of those other things,
but can we bring her in?
Yes, that would be great.
All right, Alicia, let's do this.
All right, sleep expert, Dr. Thanuja Hamilton,
is here to help.
Hi, Dr. Hamilton, how are you?
I'm great, so happy to be here.
Us too,
and I think that Alicia's case
is sounding very specific, and I think we can attack it.
What are the biggest causes of not being able to sleep?
Yeah, you know, there are a number of things
that control our sleep, and sometimes it can be
something insignificant or temporary,
or a lifestyle change, that can affect our sleep
and cause a chronic, persistent problem.
So, Alicia mentioned she works the double shift,
so now her schedule is all over the place,
and that's really important.
Our sleep is controlled by our circadian rhythm
or our internal clock, and it likes consistency.
So, it's important to have those consistent bedtimes
if you can.
A lot of people have Sunday night insomnia.
That's when you sleep in on your days off
or you nap all weekend long,
and then when Sunday night comes,
you've now set the stage for difficulty falling asleep
for the rest of the week.
Okay, so for the past week, Dr. Hamilton performed
a sleep experiment with Alicia
to help her examine her sleep patterns.
Dr. Hamilton, what did you find?
So, a couple of things.
For one thing, she went into REM sleep pretty quickly,
which suggests either sleep deprivation
or other sleep issues.
You also had less REM sleep, Alicia.
You were at about maybe 16%,
when normal REM sleep is 20 to 25%,
and REM sleep is very important.
That's our most restorative stage of sleep,
so it's really important to get that REM sleep.
What does she do?
The first thing to do is to prioritize your sleep.
You know, everyone sets a morning alarm
so you're not late to work or that important meeting.
I would set a bedtime alarm and, of course,
shutting off the screens.
Yes.
Shutting off the TV, shutting off the phone.
You know, when you watch something at night,
you get lost in it, or you end up,
if you start scrolling, you get stuck scrolling forever.
So, it distracts you, and the other important thing
is the blue wavelengths,
those blue lights emitted from the screens,
prevent your natural melatonin from being secreted.
Alicia, do you have blue light glasses?
No.
I make some
at Flower Eyewear, and I'm going to send you some,.
Oh, thank you so much.
They do make a difference,
and, Alicia, really quick,
do you like your job?
I absolutely love my job.
I love what I do, but on top of work,
I'm a mother of four, I'm a wife.
So, you know, the lack of sleep
definitely plays a major part in my home as well.
And you used to exercise,
I think you were in a triathlon, right?
Yes, yes.
When did you stop exercising?
Maybe about a year and a half, two years ago,
when I changed my work schedule
and I started working at this new job.
Did you find that you did sleep better when you exercise?
Can you carve that out?
I mean, if you're taking in everybody's stuff,
where are you putting it out?
(chuckling) Yeah, you're absolutely right,
I think the exercise would be beneficial.
It would make a huge difference.
It would definitely help me sleep better,
because I noticed when I was exercising,
I was sleeping better through the night
and waking up with energy and no headaches at all,
so that made a huge difference.
Well, then this is non-negotiable,
you have to get back up on that exercise horse.
Absolutely, I agree.
So, now some self-preservation,
get off that phone at night,
put those blue light glasses on, and let's fix this!
You deserve it!
Yes.
Thank you, yes, absolutely.
Okay, sorry, I got really passionate there.
Alicia, we're going to go to commercial.
Dr. Hamilton is gonna give us more tools
to help us get a good night's sleep
with some other women who are going through
the same thing, and we all deserve this.
(upbeat music)